la chronique culture de ce 27 février
deux invités sur ce plateau pour se
réchauffer au milieu de cette hiver très
froid chaud l'hiver on va en parler tout
à fait donc une page musicale et nous
recevons ce soir mon Christophe m'a fait
bonsoir vous êtes directeur du café de
la plage à Maurepas et Camille abeille
bonsoir vous êtes chargés des actions
culturelles pour le scarabée à La
Verrière alors on va commencer avec avec
vous Christophe pour nous parler donc du
chaud l'hiver donc c'est un festival
musical qui a lieu vendredi et samedi
alors dites-nous festival musical quel
est le principe
racontez-nous l'histoire de ce
rendez-vous hivernal important à
Maurepas tout à fait 13ème édition cette
année de ce rendez-vous amateur local
c'est un point très important pour nous
puisque c'est le moment dans l'année où
on peut un petit peu mettre en valeur le
travail effectué avec les groupes
amateurs locaux qui répètent au cobalt
et qui sont accompagnés par les
régisseurs de des studios de répétition
parce que ça c'est important
environ vendredi samedi que des groupes
locaux et des groupes qui travaillent
donc au cobalt d'une part et c'est vrai
que vous vouliez souligner ce lien ce
partenariat avec le COBAL puisque je
crois que ce sont les mêmes équipes qui
accompagnent je dirais sur le plan
technique musical donc c'est groupe et
ensuite vous qui les produisez le le
soir donc en concert clairement la
structure COBAL très pétition propose de
l'accompagnement au long cours au groupe
amateur c'est c'est une force des
studios de répétition qui sont équipés
de régisseurs en l'occurrence et nous au
café de la plage avons les outils pour
pour les mettre sur scène donc ce
travail très complémentaire se fait en
équipe avec donc les studios de
répétition et de et la structure de
diffusion qui a fait de la plage
d'accord donc on a deux soirées
thématiques
vendredi à partir de 20h30 pareil samedi
20h30 comment avez-vous sélectionner ces
groupes parce que c'est des groupes
locaux mais bon il a quand même fallu je
suppose mettre en place une petite
sélection c'est une édition un petit peu
particulière puisque traditionnellement
elle se diffuse à la salle des fêtes de
la ville de Maurepas et cette année
c'est la réouverture du café de la plage
après travaux on avait envie d'avoir ce
temps fort sur la structure qui est donc
le premier concert de l'établissement
nouveau on va dire et du coup on a fait
appel à des groupes un petit peu
emblématiques un petit peu solide sur
les avec lesquels on travaille depuis
maintenant plusieurs années donc le
choix a été très compliqué il a suffi
d'ouvrir les portes on a travaillé
pas esthétique musicale plutôt les
choses un petit peu chaudes reggae funk
groove sur sur le vendredi et les
esthétiques de la famille rock sur le
samedi l'histoire de pouvoir aussi
accueillir un maximum de personnes
puisque la salle du café est plus petite
que celle de la salle des fêtes
par thématique d'esthétique quoi le café
de la plage qui réouvre qui réouvre ses
portes donc à présent et les groupes que
vous avez mentionnés ont commencé à
prendre un petit peu la température ils
se sont rendus dans cette salle
exactement donc nous nous sommes rendus
le week-end dernier dans vos locaux et
nous avons suivi donc le groupe Air cast
System qui était en répétition et RK
system a également connu le café de la
plage avant la rénovation donc on leur a
demandé leur avis sur ces nouveaux
locaux on regarde
il va faire chaud ce week-end à Maurepas
le festival musical jolivert fait son
grand retour les premiers et de mars au
Café de la plage au programme de soirée
thématiques confiées exclusivement au
musicien locaux la première au
vibrations groove hip-hop et reggae la
seconde plus musclée sonorités rock et
métal
ce traditionnel grand rendez-vous
hivernal de Maurepas est également
l'occasion de découvrir le nouveau
bâtiment après un an et demi de travaux
900 mètres carrés d'espace au total avec
une deuxième salle de spectacle voilà de
quoi réjouir les groupes yvinois qui se
produiront ce week-end les RK systems
que nous avons suivi pendant le
répétition nous livre leurs impressions
ça a beaucoup changé là nous on était un
peu c'était un peu notre maison le café
de la plage c'est là qu'on a vraiment
fait nos premières scènes mais c'est
vrai que là matos tout neuf donc
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de potentiel
dans la salle toujours la même équipe
qui est qui connaît enfin que nous on
connaît bien et tout donc c'est quand
même la maison ça reste la maison mais
en mieux je crois parce que là il a
l'air d'avoir un acoustique vraiment
super sympa la configuration de la salle
moi en longueur plus en largeur c'est
quand même c'est quand même mieux
l'entrée est gratuite cependant une
réservation est obligatoire auprès de la
structure en guise de bienvenue un
cocktail sera offert jusqu'à 21h30
et le groupe qui se plaît dans ces
nouveaux locaux ce nouveau café de la
planète exactement enfin en tout cas
apparemment leur avis sont plutôt
positifs la scène est plus grande il y a
plus d'espace
mais alors le café de la plage c'est pas
seulement un lieu d'événements musicaux
vous accueillez aussi d'autres artistes
sur d'autres thématiques est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire de votre programmation
là jusqu'à la fin de cette saison alors
on a de la programmation musicale bien
sûr puisque c'est notre cœur d'activité
on accueille aussi des formats un petit
peu plus différents des formats catch un
pro autour de l'humour on a Arnaud de sa
mère qui revient nous faire le cadeau
d'un plateau d'humour le vendredi 7 juin
on travaille aussi de plus en plus
autour de l'action culturelle donc on
accueille des spectacles de prévention
auditive tout un tas de choses à
travailler à développer avec les jeunes
de la ville et les publics scolaires
aussi sur soi de la prévention soit de
la découverte du secteur artistique
c'est la deuxième salle en l'occurrence
qui vous donne justement un petit peu
plus de possibilités de possibilités à
explorer dans la deuxième salle mais ce
dont je ne vous parler ça se passe déjà
dans dans l'espace music actuel qu'on a
vu là sur les images d'accord sur
l'hiver donc on rappelle c'est vendredi
et samedi à partir de 20h30 chaque
soirée jusqu'à 2h du matin et donc si on
vient avant 21h30 on a le droit à un
cocktail tout à fait